asking what are you reading christopher
hitchens what are you reading right now
I'm reading well partly to review it but
now I'm just reading it because it's
such an exciting book a history of the
Dreyfus case by an Oxford woman
professor of history called Ruth Lewis I
think sorry yes it is that so isn't it
new to me really wonderful reexamination
of the greatest frame-up in history and
the revolutionary consequences that it
had for France and then because I'm
usually reading something in the fiction
line at the same time no I'm reading a
book by an author called Sebastian Barry
a brilliant young Irishman and it's
called a long long way and it's about
it's a novel about the vicissitudes of
an Irish Regiment on the Western Front
in the First World War
well they're fighting the Germans under
the British flag we're in the meantime
Irishmen are fighting under the Irish
flag against the British government back
in Dublin and so that the our civil war
is also beginning at the same time and
they're all very torn
it's Brindley done for schedule
information and descriptions of our
programs log on to book TV org you can
click on the viewer input tab and email
us tell us what you're reading and what
you think of our programs Hoover
Institution press is based in Stanford
California and we're talking with